let's go next to Dean from Dallas Dean
from Dallas welcome to the David Pacman
show what's on your mind today
I called in a couple times I don't know
if you remember me uh but I wanted to
ask a couple questions you know there
are these buzzwords which are often
associated with like a political party
like when you hear Patriot or Freedom
you think of the right wing or Maga why
doesn't the left
attempt to take the positive ones back
why do we concede those terms that can
obviously apply to the party in big ways
we've talked about this before I think
it's actually a great idea like when we
talk about what it means to be patriotic
there's a very cartoonish version on the
right and for me you know patriotism
would be hey you know what I take pride
in my country making sure no one is
starving that no one is homeless it's
like that would be a new form of
patriotism that I think would be much
more interesting and inspiring and
positive I can't answer the question why
have Democrats or the left not taken
back these terms there's a bunch of
writing about this George Lake office
talked about Republicans winning the
framing War you know I I unfortunately
Dean I Can't Tell You Why Democrats or
the left haven't done it but you're
absolutely right in diagnosing that a
lot of these terms have been kind of
perverted and certainly used exclusively
by the right to have narrow meanings and
the left should try to take them back
but I don't really know what the first
step would be
yeah and then I had a second question if
you don't mind sure do you have any
thoughts on uh cultural assimilation do
you think it's more positive or negative
or does it make us stronger as a country
or what are your opinions on it well I
think that when people talk about
cultural assimilation usually it's often
used to draw a very specific political
perspective out of people and my view on
cultural assimilation is I think one of
the things that makes the United States
great is that you do have all of these
different cultures that when things are
going well can can sort of coexist and I
think it's actually a great thing and
also I recognize that there are
difficulties that surface if you have
different types of division like when
people talk about hey this is America we
speak English here yeah listen I mean in
a practical sense this
in order to best communicate it's good
to have a shared language so I agree
with the idea that if someone comes to
the United States and lives in the
United States for 30 years and speaks no
English that's going to be an impediment
both for them and for the rest of
society to relate I also think it's a
great thing
to understand and respect and embrace
different cultures and that includes
different languages and bilingualism and
all of these different things so the the
problem you know to say is cultural
assimilation good or bad uh to some
degree if we're all going to live
together we need to have some shared
touch points and language respect for
different religions respect for
different countries of Origins all of
these different things are really
important but to objectively just say
cultural assimilation is good or bad
gets us into the kind of black and white
thinking that often gets us nowhere
yeah it kind of seems like our country
as a whole is just it's a constant
battle since we're so split of like what
the new American dream or the American
way of living is like it used to be like
own a house you know have kids married
get and get a good job go to college and
all those things you know like it's kind
of Shifting you know people like
right-wing conservative players are
saying you know college is where you go
to get woke don't go to college or
whatever
it's
it's uh and you know where people are
making more social protests it's like
during like the Pledge of Allegiance or
you know uh the singing of The
Star-Spangled Banner or people not
standing you know it's kind of yeah and
to be clear for me the Pledge of
Allegiance is just so silly I don't even
consider it when I think about an issue
like cultural assimilation it's just
nonsense to me okay all right Dean from
Dallas appreciate the call Great
questions thank you
all right there goes Dean from Dallas
very very powerful topics I must say